hello guys my name is a channel welcome
to a little video now this little video
is here to tell you that i will be doing
a lot um dad this weekend there's going
to be pretty rushed video this one right
here because I've been working really
really hard all week to finish
everything so that I can have a clear
weekend and I can do love them there
because um well because I want to really
okay so that's the deal so i will be
doing what I'm dare this weekend Oh
Caleb under 30 it starts on Saturday
11am Australian is in standard time I
believe there is a countdown on Laden
dead calm for such compost so if you
guys don't know what time will start for
you you can go there and find out to
London datacom force that calm prob in
the description it's got like a little
countdown timer I was probably start
streaming I'll try and start screaming
like up to maybe an hour before maybe
half now before okay so around half an
hour before love and death starts I
should have a stream up on Twitter TV
for / de jure know now twitch seem to
have done something with copyright music
and whatnot so you can we play that I'm
not sure actually because I again I have
time to check that out so if anyone
knows if I can play copyright music or
not let me know here in the comments of
this video hopefully i can because
otherwise we'll be in a bit boring um if
I have to play I don't know something
that's not copyrighted anyway the point
is Twitter TV for Sasha cherno starts on
Saturday australian eastern standard
time 11am ok might be friday night for
you but that is the deal ok now i'm
gonna answer one more question because
that'll definitely come up what am I
going to use am I gonna use Java what
I'm gonna do you there is OpenGL whatnot
um the thing is and I always say this
but I have to say this again all the
time I don't know I have no idea it
depends what the theme is it depends
what ideas I have it doesn't really
depend too much on the theme obviously
because the theme is kind of like just a
little things it depends on the ideas
that I come up with based on the theme
ok which will obviously get released
when the competition starts so I have no
idea what I want to use ok dad yeah I
don't know it might be it will probably
not be c++ because I will take too long
ok not that I'm a bad super soft
programmer I'm not I've been basically
doing a non-stop for the past two years
professionally well you know for
university and whatnot and for companies
but the point is that I know for a fact
from experience that see both loss is
going to take longer to develop and
that's why I typically don't use it not
because I don't no not because I hate
I actually love it but it if I need to
do something fast java's it's just
probably the best it's also easily cross
platform on OC sharpers anyway c sharp
it kind of it's got mono framework not
everything works on both windows and mac
for C sharp java everything does ok this
is not what this video's about but can I
told you to be rushed but hopefully you
guys can listen to me talking non-stop
for like three minutes anyway the point
is I don't know what I'm going to be
using ok I would like to use something
web-based just because the more people
will be able to easily play that that
won't have to download the game java
applets of rubbish um as you know as you
probably know as you now know but so I'd
love to do something web-based maybe
with WebGL I don't know I haven't I
really don't have much experience with
WebGL so i might that might slow me down
but the point is i will not be using
engines such as unity such as libgdx i
will not be doing that I will not be I
might be doing something web-based maybe
depends on the theme depends what I
think of but either way it's going to be
an awesome time I will be streaming for
the entire two days not in a row I'll be
sleeping a lot i like sleeping but the
point is Twitter TV falls after dinner
lat them there starts this weekend I'll
see all of you there on the stream
goodbye